[Applause]
[Music]
we tend to think that the world is
organized around a small group of
enormous superpowers that pour the
strings of everything the United States
China United Kingdom and maybe until
recently Russia maybe in the future
India but what if I told you that there
are much smaller seemingly insignificant
countries that suddenly achieve gigantic
influence on a global scale what if we
were to talk about countries that are
neither the richest in the world nor do
they necessarily have nuclear weapons
large armies or even a large population
but have nevertheless managed to carve
out a niche for themselves on the
international geopolitical chessboard
well visual politic viewers in this
video we're going to give you several
examples of countries that despite being
relatively small are breaking all the
molds but first it would not be out of
place to shine a light on the Ultimate
key to its renewed influence we are
talking about what is known as soft
power and take note this could be much
more important than you might imagine
we could say that this type of strategy
or power consists of being able to
impact influence and persuade people
around the world to achieve certain
objectives in order to do this elements
such as culture values Innovation Sports
diplomacy and even philanthropy are used
it is the opposite concept of hard power
which is exercise through coercion the
use of force or threats or economic
blackmail a type of power in which not
surprisingly the great Powers have many
advantages in other words in summary
while hard power depends on Force soft
power depends on persuasion and
attraction
see as far as influence and Military
presence go we've already talked about
them in a lot of videos It's a recurring
theme on visualpolitik however what we
have rarely talked about is how any
country can expand its relevance and
international influence by resorting to
persuasion this can also be a real
Lifeline for the country's companies and
products and believe me it is no joke
many countries are already developing
this line of work so without further Ado
shall we find out which countries are
able to compete head to head with the
major Powers how exactly are they doing
it well visualpolitic viewers we are
going to look at every aspect of this
new approach do you know what we're
going to illustrate it with concrete
examples so let's get started
the emergence of Ka power
one of the countries that has most
increased its International influence
and improved its external image in
recent times is can you guess yes indeed
South Korea here on visualpolitik we
have already talked about this country
in several videos we've talked about
political economic military and even
social issues but what we've never
talked about is how this country has
become one of the most popular countries
in the world I'm sure you've heard about
K-pop or Korean series that have taken
Netflix by storm such as squid game but
long before all of that before Gangnam
Style became the most watched video on
YouTube before groups like BTS and
blackpink conquered the world and before
the movie parasite won four Oscars the
so-called Korean wave had already
conquered the Asian continent maybe even
some of you as a result of all of this
have been encouraged to try Korean food
a Cuisine that is also becoming more and
more popular
foreign
music culture and Gastronomy it may not
seem like much to us but isn't it
surprising that a country like this is
having such a global impact have you
ever thought for example about the cars
that systematically appear in Korean TV
series if you haven't take a look but
they are almost always either Hyundai
Genesis or kia we could almost talk
about a mega ad for one of this
country's most important industries and
of course we're not just talking about
cars but that's just one aspect of this
huge Global exhibition it's a kind of
exposure that in the case of South Korea
has not come out of nowhere quite the
contrary we could go so far as to say
that it has been part of a state
strategy for several decades now
you see many experts believe that
government support was key in the haleyu
the Korean wave of cultural content that
emerged in the 1990s for example in 1998
then president Kim Dae song announced
the first plan to support the haleiu
industry the aim was to boost the
cultural industry to make it a great
showcase for the country and it was not
just hot air in just three years the
public budget allocated to the cultural
industry tripled the success was so
resounding that the next government that
of Raul mulhan continued to increase
investment in the cultural industry in
fact several laws were also established
as well as government agencies aimed
exclusively at promoting this cultural
content both inside and outside the
country
[Music]
let's see yes I know what you're
thinking if it were as easy as putting
money on the table many countries could
do the same right
yes you're absolutely right in fact the
truth is that in this case the key to
success of the Korean wave was not
really the economic contribution of the
government but above all that the
process was totally directed and managed
by private companies and production
companies focused on making profits
that's to say that in this case the
government played a similar role to that
of the state of Israel in the promotion
of technology companies as we recently
told you on visual economic that is it
put up the money to support the industry
but gave it all the control with a very
clear premise they had to be competitive
on their own that is they had to make as
much money as possible and so little by
little the state was nurturing a sector
that could bring them a lot of
international visibility take a look
culture has surfaced as an indispensable
element of a nation's competitiveness
and economic resource that produces
added value to keep in peace with this
changing Louisville environment Korea
has adopted cultural diplomacy as a new
pillar of the country's diplomatic
makeup 2010 diplomatic white paper of
Korea and believe me when I tell you
that they take it quite seriously
example the South Korean Ministry of
Foreign Affairs conducts research on the
impact of how you in each country and
based on the results promotes fan
activities and cultural events another
example is that the government is
sponsoring 20 to 30 percent of a huge
one billion investment fund aimed at
growing and exporting Korean pop culture
as you can see this has not come about
by chance
[Music]
so the question is what
model well one of the objectives of this
strong commitment has been to improve
South Korea's International image a
country that since its foundation in
1948 went through a devastating war and
a succession of military dictatorships
until the 1990s dictatorships that
obviously consistently violated human
rights and contributed to the country's
rather negative image abroad for a long
time South Korea was seen as a kind of
Mega Factory run by satraps and huge
family business conglomerates that were
supported by corrupt politicians as you
can imagine that was not the best
calling card
thank you
so when democracy arrived in the country
known as the land of morning calm
politicians not only had to get down to
work to clean up the institutions but
they also had to work hard to improve
the country's image at home and abroad
and there you have it no sooner said
than done but do you know what there are
a couple of facts that can help us
understand the enormous success they
have had for example according to the
world tourism organization between 1995
and 2019 which is the latest
pre-pandemic data the number of tourists
received by South Korea grew by 367
percent from about 3.75 million to
almost 18 million thus tourism is
becoming a huge and entirely new source
of income
[Music]
another fact that demonstrates the
influence that this cultural commitment
has had is the number of people who
suddenly decides to study their language
we can look for example at the number of
students who sign up for official exams
every year and take note the number of
topic applicants has increased by almost
000 between 1997 and 2019 in 2019 there
were some 400 000 applicants almost four
times more than those who signed up for
example for the official dele Spanish
exams and let's not forget that Korean
is a minority language globally with
just over 80 million native speakers
making those figures a real milestone
[Music]
as a comparison it should be noted that
Spain spends 170 million euros every
year on the Cervantes Institute
basically on its head office branches
and public employees an institution
whose essential function is to promote
Spanish around the world well what can I
say with the data in hand South Korea's
commitment to private Enterprise and
competitive content has clearly been
much more successful especially if we
also take into account that the Spanish
language has the second highest number
of native speakers and is much much more
influential in the world but let's not
get sidetracked
thank you
the fact is that all this impact
obviously translates into a huge extra
source of revenue for the South Korean
economy and that's not all it is also a
way to promote South Korea's political
image to the rest of the world which in
addition to increasing trade diplomatic
and political exchanges could be
particularly important in the event of a
conflict for example with North Korea it
is clear that the things we know and
value matter much more to us it is a
strategy that countries like Israel are
now also following have you noticed that
there is more and more Israeli content
on streaming platforms well take notes
because its implications are more
important than we might think take a
look for example at this news item
Builders season 4 breaks viewership
records in the Middle East Netflix's
controversial show folder tops Arab
countries watch list Fowler is a series
focused on the israeli-palestinian
conflict a Hebrew produced series that
is now helping to change the image of
this conflict in Arab countries it is an
incredibly powerful loudspeaker of
course the use of culture is just one
example but it is far from the only way
to achieve similar objectives there are
other possible strategies that can turn
a remote and all relatively small
country in terms of population into an
influential Global power do you want to
know more then stay tuned
[Music]
the power of the wallet
apart from movies TV series and music
which are undoubtedly excellent tools
for improving a country's image the
truth is that there is still a lot more
a very clear example is the case of
Qatar and no don't worry because we're
not going to talk about the Qatar World
Cup again although the truth is that
this event had a lot to do with
everything we are talking about an
example of a huge political marketing
campaign and an economic one however
there is still something more important
than that you see as many of you
probably already know Qatar is one of
the largest hydrocarbon exporters in the
world it specializes mainly in the
export of liquefied natural gas which
has made it one of the richest countries
on the planet Qatar has money Galore and
you know what there's a way to use that
stash of cash to not only get
profitability but also influence as
we've already told you in the past the
Emirate of the Persian Gulf invests a
large pile of the profits from
hydrocarbon exploitation through a
sovereign fund called the Qatar
investment Authority
[Music]
this fund has more than 450 billion
dollars in assets which amounts to more
than 150 000 per resident and more than
one million dollars per Qatari National
well the bulk of all this money some 400
billion dollars is invested in 80
different countries with the United
Kingdom having the largest number of
Qatari Investments with sub 40 billion
for example the qataris owned some 12
billion dollars in real estate
properties throughout the UK in addition
this fund is also the largest owner of
real estate in London while it also has
significant investments in bricks and
mortar in cities such as Paris and
Washington DC
[Music]
the truth is that the list could go on
ADD infinitum but of course we are not
just talking about buildings we're
talking Above All About strategic bets
for example qatar's claws also reach
into the realm of critical
infrastructure the country has been
buying all or part of ports and
liquefying natural gas terminals in the
rest of the world and it also has stakes
in a lot of multinationals for instance
they are one of the largest shareholders
of the Volkswagen group evidently the
control of these pieces of
infrastructure and its presence in the
shareholding of many large companies
gives the Qatari government enormous
influence over the entire planet but
wait a minute because that's not the end
of it Qatari money also has other more
alternative uses
and their quest for political and social
influence they have invested heavily in
the World of Sports without going any
further I'm sure you all know this Qatar
owns Paris Saint-Germain football club
it is their Flagship and now they want
to take control of Manchester United as
well likewise the Arab world's leading
television network Al Jazeera is also
Qatari in other words Qatar is
leveraging oil and gas money to seek not
only profitability but also political
and economic influence controlling huge
media Outlets major soccer clubs
critical infrastructure and large
shareholdings in some of the world's
most important multinationals the
qataris are always welcomed through the
front door despite being a country of
just 2.7 million inhabitants of which
just over 300 000 are Nationals it is an
extraordinary use of money to achieve
not only profitability but also soft
power Doha has become one of the great
political capitals of the Arab world and
the checkbook has played a key role
without going any further Qatari money
has also served to boost its Brotherhood
with turkey and yes it is true that
Qatar has also developed many actions of
a strictly political nature so such as
supporting the Muslim brothers or of a
military nature such as giving the
United States the largest military base
in the Middle East but the truth is that
the checkbook has played a key role in
making Doha much more important and
influential than for example Kuwait a
potentially even wealthier country let's
just say that taking advantage of
available resources to gain influence is
another key to soft power it may seem
obvious to you but the truth is that it
is not so common but before ending this
video we cannot Overlook a third way
that relatively small countries have at
their disposal to become great political
powers in addition to the use of culture
and money do you know what we are
referring to well listen up
Kings of Hearts
[Music]
another way to compete with the most
powerful countries in the world is to
become a standard Bearer for just causes
and political projects to tell you about
this we're going to give you two very
different examples Canada and Cuba we're
talking about two countries that play in
totally different geopolitical spheres
but that have managed to exploit their
strengths to achieve Regional and even
International relevance now the question
is how did they do it well in the case
of Canada what they did was to become a
standard Bearer for civil liberties and
Environmental Protection for example
Canada has been one of the countries
that has taken the UN Declaration on the
rights of indigenous peoples most
seriously and yes I know what you're
thinking this all sounds lovely but can
you really achieve International
influence with these things well the
truth is yes this could be one of the
key tools for achieving it and Canada is
a clear example of this
this North American country has been one
of the major promoters of important
International treaties for example there
is the Ottawa treaty signed in 1997
which seeks to ban anti-personnel mines
or the 1987 Montreal protocol which sets
guidelines for reducing the use of
chlorofluorocarbons in order to protect
the ozone layer
[Music]
and many of you may find all these
things irrelevant but the truth is that
they all contribute to building a
country's brand and increasing its
International influence think of it this
way everyone wants to be close to the
most popular person in the class and
this is something that affects
governments companies Investments
products and professionals it is in a
way the marketing campaign of a lifetime
applied to countries but what about Cuba
why have we included such an
impoverished country in this video if
it's a Communist dictatorship
[Music]
well although it may seem contradictory
that's precisely the point a country as
poor as Cuba which has neither money nor
significant companies nor a modern Army
nor practically anything else has
managed to become one of the most
influential countries in the Americas
how did it achieve this well by
resorting to political strategies in a
past video here on visualpolitik we saw
how they used doctors that would be one
example but Cuba goes much further as if
it stands out for anything it has been
precisely for making intense use of the
populist strategy that we could
summarize as the subjugated countries
versus the United States and Europe
which are great imperialist and
exploiting Powers this discourse has
been bought and bought a lot in many
Latin American countries such as
Venezuela where the Cubans first managed
to establish a puppet dictatorship
through Hugo Chavez then with
Venezuela's own oil money they were able
to finance their own Revolution
throughout the rest of Latin America the
idea seems brilliant maybe evil but
brilliant
[Music]
throughout the continent Cuba has
promoted political parties social
pressure groups and even International
forums such as the well-known Sao Paulo
Forum spaces from which politicians such
as Rafael Correa Evo Morales Daniel
Ortega and Manuel celaya emerged the
idea on which the Cuban influence in
Latin America was built was quite
pragmatic the Castro regime realized
that the left would not succeed in Latin
America if it did not shed at least in
the face of the gallery the old dogmas
dogmas such as ending private property
or establishing proletarian
dictatorships
[Music]
ideological question what interest could
Cuba have in exporting its revolution
well for many analysts its primary
objective would be precisely to
guarantee the very existence of the
Cuban regime with the demise of the
Soviet Union in the early 1990s and the
severe economic and social crisis this
caused in the Caribbean country the
Castro has realized that they needed an
international support network a network
that had to be in Latin America
countries that are close to each other
speak the same language and have more or
less the same culture and you know what
it turned out well and new stories like
this one are just proof of how a small
backward and poor country achieved
enormous International influence fifty
percent of the gasoline produced by
Venezuela is sent to Cuba a union leader
from that country says only 10 of the
gasoline that is being produced reaches
the population anyway as you can see
there are many ways to achieve
International influence despite being a
relatively small country
[Music]
from South Korea's cultural content to
Cuba's revolutionary policy from qatar's
macroeconomic Investments to Canada's
philanthropy what is clear is that if
you can develop some creativity with
good global vision virtually any country
can become a major power in geopolitical
influence I make no doubt about it all
the countries we've seen in this video
have reaped great benefits with this
type of strategy so it's no trivial
matter but now at this point it's your
turn do you think that your country
could follow the example of one of these
countries to have more International
presence do you think that this kind of
power of Attraction is lasting over time
leave us your comments down below and
remember if you like this video don't
forget to like And subscribe to our
channel so you don't miss any news once
again thank you so much for being there
all the best see you next time
[Music]
foreign